ANGLE".
>> Laura: IT'S TIME FOR SEEN
AND UNSEEN SEGMENT WHERE WE
EXPOSE THE BIG CULTURAL STORIES
OF THE DAY.
ALL RIGHT, KIDS BEING USED AS
PATHETIC POLITICAL PROPS, , NO
IT CAN'T HAPPEN.
AT THE END OF LADIES FIRST AND
RESTAURANTS AND THE POWER OF
SAFE AT D-DAY AND BEYOND.
RAYMOND, KIDS HAVE BEEN
STARTING TO QUIZ CANDIDATES ON
REALLY COMPLICATED
CONSTITUTIONAL MATTERS.
THEY AREN'T BEING COACHED, ARE
THEY?
>> OH NO, LAURA.
THEY'RE POPPING UP ALL OF A
SUDDEN AT POLITICAL EVENTS.
JOE BIDEN ANSWERING A KID FROM
NEW HAMPSHIRE YESTERDAY, WATCH.
>> DO YOU THINK IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDINGS SHOULD START?
>> HOW OLD ARE YOU?
>> 11.
>> I'M NOT LOOKING FORWARD TO
AN IMPEACHMENT PROCESS.
I THINK IT WOULD BE A BIG
DISTRACTION ON THINGS WE SHOULD
FOCUS ON GETTING DONE.
THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS
THERE IS A CONSTITUTIONAL
OBLIGATION.
MY JOB IS TO IMPEACH HIM A
DIFFERENT WAY, BEAT HIM.
>> UNLESS WE'RE CHANGING THE
VOTING AGE TO 11, WHY IS HE
MAKING A PITCH TO LITTLE
CHILDREN?
>> Laura: KIDS SAY THE
DARNEDEST THINGS.
>> HERE IS PETE BUTTIGIEG
RESPONDING TO A YOUNG GIRL
AFTER SHE ASKED HOW DO YOU BEAT
TRUMP IN 2020?
>> CAN'T PLAY HIS GAME, YOU
KNOW.
HE IS REALLY MEAN AND HE LIKES
TO CALL PEOPLE NAMES AND IF WE
DO IT HIS WAY I THINK WE'LL
LOSE.
WE HAVE TO CHANGE THE WHOLE
GAME.
>> IF THEY WERE TEACHING KIDS
TO BE LITERATE OR TRYING TO
BUILD THEM UP.
THEY'RE DEMONIZING THE OPPONENT.
WHICH IS WHAT I THOUGHT WAS
CALLED BULLYING.
POLITICIANS HAVE DIFFERENT
ARGUMENTS.
THEY HAVE POLICY DIFFERENCES.
>> Laura: I HAVE AN IDEA, LET
KIDS BE KIDS FOR A WHILE BEFORE
THEY GET SWIM IN THE TOXIC SOUP
OF WHAT WE DO?
>> WHAT 11-YEAR-OLD IS
CONCERNED ABOUT ANY OF THESE
GUYS OR IMPEACHMENT.
>> Laura: I'M GLAD BIDEN IS
TAKING THE HARD QUESTIONS.
THEY'LL LET THE 11 YEAR OLDS AT
HIM EVERY DAY.
>> SAY GOODBYE TO THE MOMENTS
LIKE THIS AT RESTAURANTS.
THIS IS OVER.
>> MR. MORRIS.
>> I'M JIM MORRIS.
>> THIS FIREBALL IS MY
GRANDSON, DAVID.
>> I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE
FIREBALL PART BUT GRANDSON IS
TRUE ENOUGH.
>> THIS IS A FRIEND OF MINE,
VIVIAN WARD.
>> RISING FOR A LADY IS
APPARENTLY OUT.
NOW THERE IS A NEW TREND THAT
EMERGED LAST SUMMER AND PICKING
UP STEAM.
RESTAURANTS ARE SAYING GOODBYE
TO SOFT SEXISM.
IN CHICAGO IT OMITTED THE IDEA
OF LADIES FIRST, ELIMINATED
LANGUAGE LIKE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AND THEY NO LONGER
SERVE IN ORDER OF GENDER
PERFORMANCE.
>> Laura: WHAT IS THAT?
>> I OBJECT TO THAT.
MEN AND BOYS LEARN RESPECT BY
DOING THINGS.
WHEN YOU RISE WHEN A LADY
ENTERS THE ROOM OR PULL A CHAIR
FOR A LADY IT IS SHOWING
RESPECT.
PEOPLE WANT WOMEN TO BE
RESPECTED AND THEY SHOULD BE.
LET'S SHOW AND TEACH MEN AND
YOUNG BOYS HOW TO DO THAT.
LET LADIES GO FIRST.
>> Laura: YOU KNOW WHAT I DO?
MY SON AND I WERE GOING INTO A
RESTAURANT.
I LET THE DOOR CLOSE AND I WAIT
OUTSIDE WHEN HE GOES IN.
MOMMY, WHAT HAPPENED?
YOU DIDN'T OPEN THE DOOR FOR ME.
THEY LEARN.
IT IS KIND OF FUN TO SEE THE
LITTLE KIDS DO THAT.
>> I IMAGINE IF THE WAITER CAME
OVER AND I SAID I'LL HAVE A
HAMBURGER AND YOU JUST GET
WAITED ON DOWN THE LINE.
>> I'M A THROWBACK, THAT'S MY
PROBLEM.
>> BEFORE WE GO DURING THE
PRESIDENT'S STATE VISIT TO
ENGLAND THERE WAS A LOT OF TALK
ABOUT FAITH AND SACRIFICE.
THE FACT THAT THE PRESIDENT
CHOSE TO HIGHLIGHT THE ALLIANCE
WITH BRITAIN AND WHAT BINDS US
AT THAT FIRST STATE DINNER.
>> THE BONDS OF FRIENDSHIP
FORGED HERE AND SEALED IN BLOOD
ON THE HALLOWED BEACHES WILL
ENDURE FOREVER.
OUR SPECIAL RELATIONSHIP IS
GROUNDED IN COMMON HISTORY,
VALUES, CUSTOMS, CULTURE,
LANGUAGE, AND LAWS.
OUR PEOPLE BELIEVE IN FREEDOM
AND INDEPENDENCE AS A SACRED
BIRTHRIGHT AND CHERISHED
INHERITANCE WORTH DEFENDING AT
ANY COST.
>> TODAY HE INVOKED PRAYER.
THE PRAYER THAT FDR INTONED AS
OUR MEN TOOK THE BEACHES AT
NORMANDY.
THE PRESIDENT AT PLYMOUTH.
>> THEY WILL NEED THY
BLESSINGS, THE ENEMY IS STRONG.
HE MY HURL BACK OUR FORCES BUT
WE SHALL RETURN AGAIN AND AGAIN
AND WE KNOW THAT BY THY GRACE
AND BY THE RIGHTEOUSNESS OF OUR
CAUSE, OUR SONS WILL TRIUMPH.
>> NOT ONLY FDR, EISENHOWER
INVOKED THE BLESSING OF THE
ALMIGHTY ON THIS NOBLE
UNDERTAKING.
>> A LOT OF MEN BURIED BEHIND
US HAD LITTLE BIBLES AND THERE
ARE ALSO STARS OF DAVID ON
THESE.
>> CHAPLAINS HAVING MASS FOR
THEM.
GOD WAS IN THE AIR HERE AND YOU
FEEL HIM HERE AS WELL.
>> Laura: I LIKE HIM WHEN HE